hey guys I'm Deena takfiri and this year
I'm bringing you more stories you've
seen me report from all over the world
you said you're ready to fight tonight
yes always I'll still be going abroad
but we'll also be spending more time at
home taking you places you wouldn't
otherwise see and giving a platform to
people you usually don't hear from and
why are they targeting you cuz I'm blood
and I'm a no-quit where do you see trash
cans where do you see water fountains
where do you see food it doesn't matter
that I have thought God doesn't matter
than my princess their protectors and
all of that goes above their head and
the first thing is let's call ice so
make sure you subscribe to this page to
keep up to date on my latest videos let
me know in the comments where you think
I should go a report from next